es ist gar nicht so schwer wie man
denken mag seinen kompletten knoblauch
vorrat selber anzubauen für ein jahr
dazu braucht man ungefähr zwei
quadratmeter pro person und wir haben
auf jeden fall schon in unserem
allerersten garten ja so viel knoblauch
angebaut dass wir seitdem nie wieder
welchen kaufen mussten und wie das
funktioniert das zeige ich euch in
diesem video
es gibt zwei zeit punkte zu denen man
knoblauch pflanzen kann das ist einmal
ja zum februar und märz sei es im
frühling und dann wieder im september
und oktober vielleicht auch im november
noch also bevor der winter kommt man
erntet letztendlich dickere knollen wenn
man den knoblauch schon im herbst
gepflanzt so dass der bevor der winter
kommt schon mal austreiben und vor allem
wurzeln bilden kann der über winter dann
im beet der ist nämlich richtig
frosthart und hat dann einfach im
frühling den kleinen wachstumsvorsprung
aber ihr könnt genauso gut auch jetzt
knoblauch stecken weil sich daraus fast
genauso viele knollen entwickeln werden
wie aus dem die man im herbst plant
dafür schnappt ihr euch einfach mal
knoblauch der in deutschland angebaut
wurde man bekommt den oft im bioladen
oder auch wochen mal und das ist relativ
wichtig weil viele clubs wird auch in
china angebaut und in spanien und da
sind natürlich die klimatischen
bedingungen ganz andere und deswegen
wollen wir eine sorte erwischen die
jetzt auch gut mit unserem klima zurecht
kommt man kann mit knoblauch auch als
pflanzgut im internet bestellen weil
gerade jetzt im frühling ist es wird
manchmal relativ schwer im bioladen noch
deutschen knoblauch zu bekommen
verschiedene sorten die ich euch
empfehlen kann ich habe gute erfahrungen
gemacht mit dem sorten moral weil ja
doch so spricht man den aus und wie kann
das sind alles drei supertolle knoblauch
sollten die auch richtig lecker sind und
vor allem die ersten beiden machen auch
richtig dicke knollen der dritte ist
noch ein bisschen leckerer als die
anderen hat aber einen geringeren ertrag
knoblauch kommt nicht gut mit unkraut zu
recht einfach lieber den platz für sich
und wächst sonst nicht so gut dass es
ein weiterer grund dafür kompost beete
anzulegen wir haben beete die auf
natürliche weise nahezu unkrautfrei
bleiben und das jahrelang und die ist es
auch sehr einfach die anzulegen wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie das funktioniert kann
ich euch gerne in den link unten in die
video beschreibung packen das ist ein
kostenloser micro sd nicht erstellt habe
wo ich zeige wie man seinen garten so
gestaltet dass kaum noch unkraut wächst
das kommt dem flugloch also sehr
entgegen aber wenn ihr unkraut in ihren
beeten stehen habt denn es ist ganz
wichtig dass ihr bevor ihr den knoblauch
pflanzt einmal richtig schön redet und
die beete auch bis zur ernte immer
wieder schön rettet damit die schönen
bei kraut frei sind und der knoblauch
einfach nicht so viel konkurrenz druck
hat weil damit keine aber nicht so gut
umgehen form pflanzen sprecht ihr dann
einfach die knollen auseinander und dann
nehme ich mir die dicksten szenen die
die knolle zu bieten hat und stärke die
so dass die spitze nach oben zeigt also
man sieht die haben hier unten so eine
flache seite und oben eine spitze seite
und der flachen wachsen eben die wurzeln
raus und da oben wächst der spross raus
deswegen die spitze seite nach oben und
die flache seite nach unten von ungefähr
vier bis sechs zentimeter tief
einpflanzen und zwar alle 15 cm also
alle 15 zentimeter darf ein neuer
knobloch kommen und der reihenabstand
zwischen den rhein beträgt dann 25 cm so
hat jeder knoblauch genug platz richtig
schön groß und dick zu werden ich bin ja
ein großer fan von mulch das heißt ich
denke meine beete ganz gern mit
organischen material abseits stroh oder
holzhackschnitzel oder rasenschnitt so
dass der boden schön feucht bleibt und
der möglich verrottet auch nach und nach
unterdrückt eben auch bei kräuter die
wenn du immer aufgehen könnten und
deswegen muss ich natürlich auch meinen
knoblauch der knoblauch mag aber
besonders gegen sommer eher trocken
stehen weil er sonst anfängt zu faulen
und dann können wir ihn nicht mehr so
gut lagern deswegen verteidigt um einen
knoblauch herum nur eine ungefähr fünf
zentimeter dicke mulchschicht ich
verwende sei auch kein rasenschnitt weil
er auf sehr feucht und klebrig wird
sondern lieber holzschnitt sie die
trockene nämlich ein bisschen besser ab
dicker würde ich den nicht wohin und es
ist auch wichtig dass wir im sommer da
nicht zuviel gießt weil er eben eher
trocken stehen muss damit die knollen
richtig schön ausreifen und der nicht
anfängt zu faulen und wenn ihr im mai
merkt dass er ja so ein bisschen gelbe
blätter schon bekommt im juni und juli
ist es normal dass die blätter langsam
geld werden aber wenn das schon im mai
passiert dann heißt es das ja eine
kleine dünger ladung gebrauchen könnte
sein könnt ihr zum beispiel eine
brennende auto verdienen und den damit
gut düngen oder einem biologischen
flüssigdünger geben dann habt ihr
vielleicht noch ein bisschen dick nett
wenn ihr das nicht machen würde aber
wenn die blätter nicht geld werden dann
müsst ihr das auch überhaupt nicht
machen in richtung sommer entwickeln die
pflanzen dann außerdem kosten die wollen
dann anfangen zu blühen und das bedeutet
dass sie nicht mehr so viel kraft da
reinstecken schön dicke knolle zu beten
und deswegen brechen wir die kosten
immer aus die kann man auch richtig gut
essen das schmeckt wie frischer
knoblauch also
ein bisschen milder als knoblauch aber
super super lecker man kann die auch
fermentieren und einlegen und wenn man
das macht und die knospen ausbricht dann
hat man am ende eine viel größere ernte
das also nicht verpassen
und wenn es dann so weit ist ungefähr
mitte juni manchmal auch anfang juni
dann einfach mit der grabegabel in der
nähe der pflanze in den boden stechen
ein bisschen auflockern und die pflanzen
rausholen und ein cooler trick bei der
ernte ist dass man die äußersten blätter
einfach ab zieht also einfach an der
pflanze entlang abziehen weil da ist
natürlich die ganze erde dran und dann
habt ihr richtig schön sorgt
knoblauchknollen ohne dass ihr die groß
abwaschen oder putzen mist ich bin sind
wir ganz gerne immer so fünf knollen und
hängen die zusammen an einem seil im
gewächshaus auf damit die nicht schön
durch trocknen können ihr könnt das auch
unter einem überdachten vordach draußen
aufhängen so dass die luft das schön
durch streichen kann und die knollen
einfach richtig schön aus herten weil
die dann viel länger lagern können das
ist ja auch wichtig wenn man das ganze
jahr über seinen eigenen knoblauch essen
möchte dass die sich auch gut lagern
dafür packe ich die einfach in holz
körbchen man kann auch zöpfe flechten
und die knoblauch pflanzen dann also
aufhängen ich lagere die immer dunkel
einfach in der küche im schrank die
lagern sich da ungefähr bis in den april
manchmal sogar mai hinein je nach sorte
natürlich sollte man eher sorten anbauen
die man noch länger lagern kann und im
april und mai kann man schon wieder die
ersten frisch ausgetrieben und knoblauch
pflanzen ganz ernten und die erziehung
knoblauch essen auch das ganze grün kann
man da mit auf essen das schmeckt super
lecker und so schließt sich dann der
kreis dass man rund ums jahr mit dem
eigenen knoblauch versorgt ist ein tipp
habe ich noch für euch und zwar habe ich
letztes jahr einfach mal ein knoblauch
beet mit einem winter vlies abgedeckt um
dem ein bisschen kälte schutz zu geben
das brauchen die nicht also die sind
richtig vor streit aber dadurch sind die
pflanzen die unter dem vlies waren
nochmal viel schneller gewachsen und ich
hatte am ende auch eine dickere ernte
also wenn ihr noch eine fliese fliegen
haben den fakt dass ruhig mal aufs
knoblauch beet jetzt in den kalten
monaten
das funktioniert sehr sehr gut dass man
damit die knoblauch pflanzen noch ein
bisschen pushen kann es gibt da draußen
noch die mrt gemüse zum beispiel die
tomaten
die kann man jetzt wunderbar im haus
vorziehen und wenn ihr wissen wollt wie
das funktioniert dann schaut gerne mal
da drüben vorbei ansonsten geht raus und
macht die welt ein bisschen grüner und
wir sehen uns am samstag um 10 4 neues
video chats macht's gut